everybody knows malala's story they know
that you have been called the bravest
girl in the world and everybody knows
what you have gone up against including
facing down death to make your message
heard so this is an extraordinary
opportunity of course you've also been
in the news because of the Nobel Prize
an extraordinary moment there can we get
a cheer for that Malala what went
through your mind when you first heard
that you had won I was in my chemistry
class and I was focusing on a chemical
reaction etc etc and then one of my
teacher came and was quite worried I
said that what have I done
and then she told me that I have won the
Nobel Peace Prize and it was great
honour for me to hear this and it was an
honor for me because it because not many
women have won the Nobel Peace Prize so
in that sense yes a great honor that a
woman has won it then the youngest so it
also gives hope to many young children
and many young people who are working
for education that yes their work is
appreciated and what they're doing for
the cause of education matters because
sometimes we think that we are children
and what we do may not have a good
impact so it shows that our core so has
a good impact and it can bring change so
that was also a great honor that the
youngest person gets it like the
youngest nominee nominee and laureate
ever so that was a great honor and the
extraordinary thing is even describing
such a personal moment of excitement
you're so eloquent and you are so
committed to your message of empowering
other young people but take me inside on
a personal level what that's like you're
in chemistry class you're with
classmates I guess you hear this did you
do a happy dance I probably would have
like sang an embarrassing victory song
I'm sure you were more dignified and
they're good in dancing
I just stole my Tita thank you very much
and then they called an assembly in
school it was the first time that I
spoke on the stage of my school and I
was so nervous like I was not nervous at
the UN not nervous here but I was
nervous at the school and because the
teachers were there the students but
then I told them that you are very lucky
that you have such a great school with
all the facilities you have science lab
computer lab you have wonderful teachers
you you have no deficiency you have good
classrooms chairs tables everything but
there are schools or in some parts of
the world where children do not have any
facilities and some children do not have
schools at all so you should be thankful
that you have got all these facilities
and you are getting quality education so
it was a great opportunity to speak to
my friends to speak to my teachers then
I thanked all of them so I was very
happy and I think that was it I didn't
dance take us inside being in Birmingham
as a British schoolgirl now
how are those friendships do your
friends role you're their eyes when you
talk about girls education do they get
your message well I am in a very good
school and they are trying to treat me
as a normal student so when I don't do
my homework
they just don't say oh you're Malala
it's fine they say where is your
homework so I have like Noor disability
to make excuses and I don't get this
opportunity to say like oh I was very
busy I had a meeting I had an interview
that's why and I could not prepare
myself for the test so I don't have
enough good excuses and they treat me
like normal students which is good in
some we're not good in some way I said
oh can I write you a form saying you
were at the summit if you have to be
late for an assignment they wouldn't
accept it because when I when I got the
Nobel Peace Prize and at the weekend I
was very busy phone calls are coming and
I couldn't compute my English homework
so my the next day my teacher asked me
like where's your homework and I said
miss I won the prize and I was quite
busy
what is that teacher's name well I
didn't say he reck'n unison I think then
I'll get severe punishment but she
replied that I said I didn't do it
because of this busy schedule and then
she said so what so and I said ok I will
do it tomorrow